messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france françois michel en
bas vous êtes député vous étiez donc
hier à l'assemblée nationale on a parlé
de débats houleux de débats intenses qui
finalement ont abouti au vote en
première lecture de cette loi finalement
est-ce que les débats ont changé quelque
chose
voit les débats ont surtout montré que
le gouvernement crée un capharnaüm
en bon français je devrais même dire
bordel sur le sujet avec des prises de
positions qui sont aléatoires des fois
c'est assez clair d'autres fois c'est
beaucoup moins claires voire certains
peuvent avoir des dérogations il crée
énormément de confusion et finalement on
n'avance pas a ajouté être extrêmement
clair mots j'ai arrêté les débats à
l'assemblée nationale jeudi à 20 heures
parce que j'ai pris mon train afin
d'avoir ma deuxième vaccination le à
8h30 le vendredi matin de ma position
elle est extrêmement clair je pense que
la vaccination est une des solutions il
faut y aller mais la façon dont se prend
ce gouvernement mais il n'y a pas pire
que pour repousser l'intérêt à la
vaccination
les gens s'en inquiète j'ai rencontré
hier le colonel des pompiers du
département qui m'a dit qu'une grande
partie de ces sapeurs pompiers
volontaires et bien nous pas franchement
envie vu le la situation d'être vacciné
et donc ils vont proposer leur démission
qu'est ce qu'on va faire qu'on aura 10
ou 20% les sapeurs pompiers qui ont posé
leur démission parce que ils n'ont pas
été vaccinés parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
passeport sanitaires voilà c'est ça la
confusion qui a été créée par le
gouvernement est absolument pas
dynamique un enthousiasme et finale
alors d'où vient me permettez moi ce
terme ait au moins donner envie d'être
vacciné il a créé la défiance philippe
madrelle en quoi ce pass sanitaire nous
semble-t-il nécessaire à l'heure
actuelle en france via le pass sanitaire
nous paraît nécessaire parce que c'est
une façon de protéger de les personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui qui peuvent être
vulnérables ou qu'ils peuvent
voilà qui peuvent être contaminés par
d'autres personnes donc c'est utile et
je rappelle qu'il a été adopté quand
même par plusieurs pays européens le
danemark l'autriche le portugal bientôt
l'italie
voilà donc ça me paraît nécessaire mais
nous avons cependant deux réserves sur
le sur le hassani terre le premier c'est
le coup puisque on peut faire un pcr si
on est pas si on n'est pas vacciné et le
fait que le pcr soit assez cher nous
parraine un problème donc nous sommes
favorables d'une part parce que le pcr
soit gratuit pour les soignants qui
voudraient passer à vacciner qui vaut a
néanmoins continué à travailler et
qu'ils soient partiellement remboursés
pour les autres personnes de façon à ce
qu'il soit incitatif si vous voulez que
le ce soit incitatif sans être
prohibitifs françois michel lambert
josée vu tout à l'heure
lever les yeux au ciel je vais vous
laisser répondre à notre invité jean
temps record il dit le passé éclaire
existe un réseau de pays prenant juste
l'italie et regarder comment c'est
simple en italie en italie c'est le pass
annie terre pour rentrer dans les
restaurants dans l'est dans les lieux de
fréquenter mais en terrasse il ne l'est
pas et c'est pour tout le monde et il
n'ya pas les policiers n'ont pas
l'obligation d'être vaccinés ou d'avoir
même impasse sanitaires pour les
transports en commun on ne fait pas la
différence comme on fait en france si
vous prenez les tgv
vous n'aurez pas besoin avant en prenant
le métro de passe à lithaire arrivée à
la gare tgv vous en aurez besoin
je vois pas trop la grande différence en
termes de transport que vous soyez dans
un métro ou dans un tgv c'est cette
crispation créé par le gouvernement qui
est extrêmement problématique
mais au-delà de ça je voudrais dire deux
choses la première la france est dans
une situation par rapport à la
vaccination problématique
nous avons dix points de retard par
rapport à l' espagne italie nous étions
à égalité nous avions autant de citoyens
vacciner début juin 15 juillet nous
avons 10% de 22 de citoyens en moins
vacciner qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant un mois et demi qu est ce qu a
fait le gouvernement rien est-ce qu'il a
incité rien est ce qu'il a donné les
moyens de
deux campagnes de vaccination large est
ce qu'il a fait des campagnes de
communication au contraire il a dit mais
ça y est le temps des jours heureux est
revenu et il ya eu un relâchement
il a même anticipé le déconfinement donc
on a eu une baisse de vaccination en
france contre contrairement à l'espagne
à l'italie est aujourd'hui ce retard en
le paillis mais on va pas le payer à
coup de bâton c'est mon deuxième point
tel qu on le fait avec ce pass
sanitaires il faut aussi trouver
d'autres solutions
c'est les amendements que j'ai proposé
qu' évidemment n'ont pas été retenus
c'est des amendements de qui et
s'inspire de ce que font certains élus
n'avaient territoire je pense notamment
au gers dans le gers
ils ont fait un maxi drive vous arriver
avant d'aller déjeuner chez la
grand-mère la famille s'arrête et ils
sont vaccinés
très simplement sans sortir de la
voiture voilà simplifions donne envie
ils sont allés même plus loin
ils ont lancé un tirage au sort pour
tous les jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans qui
seront vaccinés pourront avoir des
places de concert les vélos électriques
et donc ça donne une autre perspective
et notre enthousiasme à aller vers la
vaccination et ça aujourd'hui le
gouvernement la seule chose qui fait et
je rejoins les manifestants c'est de
tenter de scinder de fracturer la france
est aujourd'hui dans des familles à des
gens qui ne se parlent parce que le père
veut que l'enfant soit vacciné la mère
ne le veut pas et le gouvernement vient
s'immiscer au milieu je rappelle que un
seul parent peut suffire pour autoriser
la vaccination d'un mineur vous imaginez
les conflits que cela va pouvoir créer
va entraîner au sein des familles nous
avions une autre méthode comme
d'habitude ce gouvernement passe en
force avec sa certitude et sa
verticalité jupitérienne et le résultat
est bien c'est une crispation de la
france philippe madrelle qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cela c'est vrai qu'on
entend beaucoup en parler de
discrimination et que ce pass sanitaire
avec d'un côté des français vaccinés et
puis de l'autre ceux qui ne seront pas
alors d'abord nous savons c'est un autre
point souligné c'est que se passa line
est salutaire bien sûr il n'est pas
forcément évident à appliquer mais nous
avons nous pensons qu'il faudrait être
faire attention à deux endroits
particulièrement que son
les hôpitaux et les maisons de retraite
parce qu'autant nous n'avons pas de
réserves sur son utilisation
sinon 50 excité mais ce sont utilisation
dans des poses activités de sports de
loisirs autant à l'hôpital il ya un
risque de dissuasion de personnes qui ne
sont pas vaccinés qui n'ont pas ce
qu'ils n'ont pas passé le pcr et donc il
risque de commandes ya de renoncer à
aller se faire soigner par crainte
d'être rejetées dont je crois qu'il
faudrait pour permettre quand même
l'accueil de ces gens là avec un accueil
distincts le deuxième c'est maison de
retraite moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
passé beaucoup de temps j'ai besoin de
traitements 7 ans et donc il ya un
risque que certaines personnes n'avaient
pu voir leurs parents âgés
à cause de ça donc je pense qu'il
faudrait aussi un peu de souplesse et
que les personnes qui ne seront pas
n'auront pas le test pcr ou ne seront
pas vaccinés puissent quand même
bénéficié d'un accueil spécial pour
aller voir notamment des personnes
malades ou en fin de vie parce que il
faut évidemment surtout ne pas être
inhumain en la matière en ce qui
concerne la vaccination
je crois qu'il faut faire attention à
une chose c'est que nous sommes
évidemment favorables globalement à la
vaccination
mais il faudrait attendre quand même
d'avoir le résultat des études cliniques
le définitif sur les vaccins à savoir
que celle d'astrazeneca est attendu pour
la fin mai 2001 2 avant de suspendre les
personnes de leur emploi et surtout les
privait la rémunération je crois qu'il
faut être extrêmement vigilant par
rapport à ça donc nous avons nous
préconisons que les perçoit y soigne
réticents à se faire vacciner puisque
d'une part bénéficier continuez à
travailler sous le régime du test pcr ce
test est temps pour eux gratuits
deuxièmement que ensuite si s'ils ne
veulent pas passer par là qu'il puisse
être suspendue mais qui leur garantit
leur leur rémunération soient garanties
sous forme de congés rémunérés hors
primes évidemment avec la rémunération
de base et 100 et 100 avancement
sans droits à l'avancement et enfin que
lorsque sortiront les analyses
définitives des essais cliniques
eh bien ces personnes auront le choix
entre se faire vacciner
et si elles ne veulent pas faire
vacciner en haut de la donne mais avec
astrazeneca vous sous réserve évidemment
que le rapport confirme que ce vaccin
peut être administré et bien à ce moment
là ils pourront soit se mettre en congé
sans solde soit attendre le le rapport
concernant le modern acquis sortir en
décembre et auquel cas il serait mis
elles sont là en congé sans solde des
recettes entrerait en vigueur entre en
vigueur le régime de vaccination est
accompagné du licenciement mais en
attendant je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement rapide merci en tout cas
vous philippe mazel rappelle que vous
êtes président du parti les citoyens
européens
françois michel lambert vous êtes député
liberté territoire de la 10ème
circonscription des bouches du rhône et
président de liberté écologie fraternité
messieurs merci à vous d'avoir été en
direct sur arte france